okay the continued comedy of errors that
also has a major humanitarian death toll
right so we don't want to merely call it
a comedy of errors
russia has apparently shot down their
own 36 million dollar bomber jet an
airplane
um this is according to ukraine there's
a newsweek article explaining it a 36
million russian su-34 bomber was
reportedly shot down by russia's own
forces over ukraine's eastern luhansk
region according to ukrainian media
outlets yesterday the jet was reportedly
down near alchefska city in the luhansk
region this is where the war is
currently focused and all chess is
currently under the occupation
of moscow-backed separatist forces a
video and images shared by the strategic
command of the armed forces of ukraine
on the telegram messaging app
appear to show the charred remains of a
russian su-34 fighter bomber now there
is
there's some confusion about this
because there were reports that the
picture of a non-destroyed bomber is not
actually of the su-34
and uh there's some debate as to whether
the reporting is showing the right
planes or whether the reporting is
describing the right planes it appears
to be that it is an su-34
but that some of the images are not
actually of that plane which makes you
wonder
uh you know it makes you under a number
of different things although i believe
that this picture that i'm showing you
is of the su-34
you know um these types of accidents
actually do happen in in war it's not
the strangest thing and when you get
over a hundred days right i mean we're
into month four at this point of a war
where
neither side is
dramatically well organized when it
comes to air warfare uh there are
there's similar looking equipment on
both sides
it's not the most unheard of thing but
at the same time we don't currently know
um exactly how this plane was shot down
was it shot down by ground fire you
would think that any air defense
missiles
would be checking for identifiers where
planes have an identifier i guess if the
identifier system malfunctioned or if it
didn't work
maybe russian troops thought this was an
enemy bomber and they shot it down as a
result but it's a good opportunity to
kind of zoom out and talk about what's
going on in ukraine bigger picture and
it's not good
um and i've i've spoken with you before
about how
the stories that make good stories for
corporate media are stories that have a
relatively clearly defined beginning
middle and end and if you think back to
coverage of the iraq war in 2003 and the
lead-up you had
making the case for the war that was a
clear like a pre-war
phase
uh and that included the testimony
before
congress which included faulty uh
intelligence as we now know it included
george w bush making the case and
ultimately george w bush announcing the
start of the war and then it went to
missiles and the entire thing
the actual meat of the war coverage and
then you had the mission accomplished
banner and even though after that is
when most of the civilian and and uh um
uh military casualties took place after
the mission accomplished moment
there was less coverage of the war as an
event that is ongoing it became
background at that point and this is why
and i know many of you have heard this
already but i think it's important to
unders understand and for me to explain
how a lot of these corporate media
narratives kind of work uh if you have a
story like
hunger deaths among african children
which is sort of like your proto-typical
um
tragedy in the sense that it's always
going on and there's a question of well
when and how is it covered
it's ongoing
and this is why
the constant deaths of children
from hunger in africa
don't get the attention in western media
as one or two people
killed in a school shooting as an
example doesn't mean any of the deaths
are any more or less tragic uh and in
terms of preventability that that's a
whole other conversation to have as well
but
with the
invasion of ukraine by russia
we are now kind of in that middle phase
and that middle phase can be very very
long and at this point you can make the
case that nothing new is happening now
every time bombs are dropped
every time an apartment building is
bombed every time people are killed
those are new things that are happening
it's just as tragic when person 100 and
1000 is killed as when it's person
number one but the stories start to
blend and people start to say well
weren't they already in the luhansk
region was this the donetsk or what what
was it didn't i think the the the
infirmary
or the nursery was already bombed was oh
this one's in a different place and so
the coverage we're seeing in corporate
media starts to reflect that
prototypical prototypical for
independent shows like ours the
challenge becomes
how to continue covering it
um
given that the resources of shows like
ours to have people on the ground are
dramatically more limited and so to a
certain degree we we are
reacting to
the coverage that is taking place which
is certainly uh diminished at this point
but the latest news is that that this is
sort of the
individual element of the story
russia apparently shooting down one of
its own fighter jets and uh you know we
could we could call it a comedy of
errors and stop there if it weren't so
tragic